this is part of a broad and escalating
uh war on chinese tech if china decided
to turn
punitive it could really hammer the
fortunes
of certain big u.s companies it's only
been in the last
kind of three to six months that we've
seen a sea change in how donald trump
has broadened out his criticisms of
china
the big news from the front line of the
u.s china tech war
this month has been orders issued by
president trump to ban
two chinese apps tick tock and wechat
from being used in the united states
this might not sound like a big deal
but what we should realize is that these
two apps are huge
tick tock and its chinese equivalent do
yin were downloaded more times than
facebook last year and wechat is a
super app that is an essential part of
life
for many of the 1.1 billion users of it
worldwide
i'm pretty sure for a start that donald
trump is not using wechat
to talk to his his friends in asia and
i'm pretty sure as well that he's not
posting videos himself
dancing on tick tock so we can rule that
out
i think what's happened is that this is
part of a broad and escalating
uh war on chinese tech that itself is
part of a wider campaign by the trump
administration to clamp down on china
on a whole range of things from trade
and the economy
to espionage now when it comes to
tick-tock i mean tick-tock is also
hugely popular in america particularly
with younger people who post
you know songs and dancing and have fun
with it
so to many people you might say what is
the threat from this app
and when you ask that question the
answer that always comes back is
data the u.s says that ultimately that
data
either is going back or could go back to
the communist party
and that the chinese government could
then use that in many different ways so
for example it could use that data to
try and
work out you know who is an american cia
operative in china i think the other
thing to mention about wechat which is
slightly different
is that one of the concerns there that
the trump administration has
is that the chinese government
essentially monitors wechat or uses it
to spy on its own citizens
the us doesn't like that as a
stand-alone fact but it's also worried
that
any americans who use wechat to
correspond with anyone
are also having their communications
intercepted by the chinese government so
it's
this is part of a campaign to kind of
purge the international
uh you know technological universe of
chinese technology and chinese apps
well so far china's been relatively
restrained
it did last year threatened to put u.s
companies on what it calls an
unreliable entities list but so far it
hasn't put any companies on that list
however there is a fear that if china
decided to turn punitive
it could really hammer the fortunes of
certain big u.s
companies for example apple relies on
china for its manufacturing base
and about one-fifth of its global
revenues
come through the sale of iphones and
other products in china
and there is also a question actually
over whether or not apple could get hit
by this ban
in the us on wechat that's because the
scope of this ban
is not yet clear but some lawyers think
that it could extend to china
and if that happened it could give
chinese consumers the very unenviable
choice of
either keeping their wechat app or
keeping their apple iphone and given
that wechat is such an essential part of
life i mean
people do digital payments over it they
they do wealth management over it they
they buy their shopping they do all
kinds of daily things
on their wechat that they may well
decide to drop their iphone
under those circumstances and that could
really
hit apple hard the other industry
um in which u.s companies are very much
dependent on china
is semiconductors and in fact the five
u.s chip companies nvidia texas
instruments
qualcomm intel and broadcom all depend
on china for
between about one quarter and one
half of their global sales so if
china targets them it could really hit
them badly
[Music]
when it comes to donald trump himself i
think it's probably a little bit of both
certainly on the emotional side donald
trump is very angry at china because of
coronavirus he blames
the chinese communist party for letting
the virus kind of spread ripple out of
china and spread around the world
in terms of evidence his national
security team they will say that there
is evidence that
china uses some of these apps to spy
obviously journalists have been chasing
these kind of stories now for a long
time and
huawei which is the big telecoms
equipment maker has been
you know in the crosshairs of american
foreign policy now for a while but the
u.s has never publicly
put out any evidence showing that it
spies on behalf of china
and one of the problems america has had
around the world is that many countries
have said
you're telling us to ban huawei or
you're telling us to ban other apps
but you haven't shown us the evidence to
prove that there's nefarious activity
there's two possibilities here it's
either that there's no evidence
of something malign happening so far
but the american national security
officials believe that the potential for
that to happen is very strong
another possibility is that the way the
u.s
has gained intelligence on some of the
things that it says china is doing
is so sensitive that they don't want to
reveal it
uh but at the moment we just don't know
so we're being told to
to go on faith to to trust that the
concerns are real
um and i think given the way that china
operates in xinjiang for example where
it's using
facial recognition technology and and a
whole slew of things to commit what
many people say human rights abuses you
can see why
just to mention that these threats are
possibly there
would resonate with other governments
around the world but but again we just
we just don't know so we haven't seen
anything publicly that would back up a
lot of these claims
if you think back to the first three
years of trump administration
donald trump was very tough on china
when it came to trade but over the first
three years
he was very reluctant to hit back
against china on other things for
example
when china clamped down on democracy
protests in hong kong
we know that donald trump said to xi
jinping at the g20
in osaka last year that basically trump
would not be critical
uh because he didn't want to derail
trade talks it's only been
in the last kind of three to six months
that we've seen a sea change in how
donald trump
has broadened out his criticisms of
china and i think
one of the big things that's driving
that which we mentioned a little earlier
is trump is really angry at china over
coronavirus
rightly or wrongly he thinks the
american economy was doing fantastically
well
until covert 19 hit now the u.s like
many other countries is really suffering
he blames china for that he's clearly
decided that china is going to be a
boogeyman for the 2020 election
in a similar way that he bashed china
back in 2016 and it worked for him
and so i think he's decided that there's
no point now taking a soft approach on
china
he has very little to gain i think what
you're also is happening at the same
time is a lot of his national security
hawks
who've been trying to push him and have
been frustrated that he wasn't going to
do more over the last few years
they've now seen an opportunity to once
again kind of rev up their
um actions and get him on board and push
him to do certain things that he was
resistant to do before
so i think you know wechat and tick tock
probably fall into that category
so i think we're going to see a
continued
slew of actions against china over the
next three months
by donald trump i think the incentive
for him not to hit china has really
dissipated and the only question is how
far is he willing to go
uh i think the one red line for him is
probably the american stock market he
likes to say that even though the
economy is doing badly and
more than 160 000 people have died from
coronavirus here
the stock markets are almost at record
levels
uh if he does something that triggers a
response from china which then
causes the american stock markets to
plummet i think it would be a huge risk
for him and what about biden if he wins
is the complexion of u.s china relations
going to change
joe biden is going to be
whether you agree with his policy or not
he's going to be i would say less
unpredictable than donald trump he's
unlikely to be making policy by tweet
uh i suspect that there will be a more
organized national security
decision-making process
which will probably make it easier for
the chinese to deal with the u.s
on one level on the other hand it's also
clear that in washington
uh the kind of hawkish view towards
china
is not limited just to the trump
administration and his political
appointees
all across washington the on the
spectrum of doves to hawks
pretty much everyone has shifted in a
more hawkish direction
uh capitol hill at the moment is famous
for you know gridlock and partisan
fighting
pretty much the only area where
democrats and republicans agree
is on the need for the u.s to take a
tougher stance on china
so i think no matter what happens even
if biden wins
you're still going to see a tougher view
towards china
than you did at the end of the obama
administration and the question really
is just how far will biden go
and what kind of relationships will he
try to establish with the chinese and
and where are biden's red lines
and i think when donald trump and joe
biden debate on the debate stage they're
gonna have three presidential debates
i imagine that china is going to be one
topic that there's going to be a lot of
questions about so people will be
watching very closely to see
you know who is joe biden when it comes
to china and
how different will he be from donald
trump